- Thank you for
being here of course.
- Thank you, Chris,
thank you, thank you.
And also thank you to everyone
who has donated to the
Reading Rainbow Kickstarter.
So far you all butterflies
in the sky in my heart.
- Yes,
(clapping and cheering)
you guys crushed it.
I'm so glad, this actually
gives me faith in the
internet and humanity.
- It does, doesn't it?
- It is nice, yeah.
- But there are still
some doubters out there.
- Do you want me to murder
them, I'll kill them.
I will kill them for you.
- No, no no.
(laughing)
- Okay, sorry.
- So.
- Sorry I got excited.
- I wanted to show your audience
the effect on a generation
of kids who grew up
without Reading Rainbow.
- Alright.
- To do that I am going to
read you some words I found
on urbandictionary.com.
(audience laughing)
And their definitions.
- Sure.
(audience laughing)
- Okay, so craydar,
craydar is defined as
a man's ability to see
whether or not a
woman be cray cray,
(audience laughing)
or not.
- Yeah, sure, of course.
- Okay so comedians my
question for you is how
is the word book defined
on Urban Dictionary?
Is it?
(audience laughing)
A, an object used as a
coaster to increase the height
of small children or
increase the stability
(audience laughing)
of poorly built furniture?
And before you answer
I must point out
that on
urbandictionary.com height
is spelled H-I-G-H-T.
(audience laughing)
- This guy didn't
have Reading Rainbow.
- I'm just sayin'.
- If you guys had
Reading Rainbow height's
spelled right there.
- I'm just sayin', or B
is it an object your
grandma uses to hit you
when you interrupt her
viewing of an episode of NCIS?
(audience laughing)
- Yeah, you don't
want to do that.
- Or is it C, an object
hobos use to start fires?
(audience laughing)
(bell rings)
- [Chris] Feels like
all of them, Jimmy.
- I'm uncomfortable
with all of them.
(audience laughing0
I'm a fan of B, I'm
gonna go with B.
- Alright, the correct
answer is in fact A.
- [Audience] Oh.
- No points.
Here's a little trick
to spot the real one
@midnight look for the
spelling error that's the one
that came from the internet.
(laughing)
These people did not
know what a boooo-k was.
(audience laughing)
Guys please support Reading
Rainbow Kickstarter,
continue to support it
at helpreadingrainbow.com
so that kids remember
what books are again.
Give it up for LeVar Burton.
(audience cheering)
Thank you, LeVar.